600人本当におめでとう！これからもがんばってください。
ありがとうございます。
もう600いってるやん
ありがとうございます
600万人おめでとう！！
は、はあss...
ありがとうございます
（みんなからの大量のおめでとう）
ありがとござああああああああ
すあっ
せあっ
さいっ
はい、こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです！
はじめしゃちょーチャンネル、チャンネル登録者…
600万人超えましたー！！！
(ｇｒｒｇｆｆｓｆ
ありがとうございますぅぅ泣
ふぁぁ…もう訳がわかんないよォ…
日本の人口だと約２０人に一人ぐらいは僕のチャンネルを登録してる計算になるので...
怖いです
素直に怖いです
やば　俺、全然そん...うええええええ
自覚が全く足りないんですけども、まあ
まあ今後も変わらず、あの、くそつまｎ
まあ、しょうもない
みなさんの暇つぶしになれるような動画を出していこうと思いますので、
これからも、宜しくお願い致します。
というわけでッ！！！！
質問コーナー！！
やっていきます
そして、言っていたとおり！
動画の最後に
ちょっと重大なお知らせがある...ので...
ぜｆｊｈｊｈ
飛ばさないで質問コーナー
では行こうッ
助けてぇぇぇぇ
はいッ
何見てんだよ！
さーせん！！
いや、全然やりますけどね
FIRE！
ああああ。もうもうもう知らねえぞぉ
もお俺知らないからね、これ
あ、間違えたけんけんけんになっちった
やべ　あの人これ普通に怒りそうなんですけどー
ブォーン
ざけんなァッ！
なにこれなにこれなにこれ
すげぇ無限にしみ込むっ！
いやこれうまいのかな
いただきます
そうでもねえや
いきます
（着信音）
さすがに忙しいかな...
多分忙しいんですよ親分...
ん？
すきすき家！！！
大きな声で～発狂　せーのっ！
uワああああああああぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ
ワアアアぁぁぁぁぁ
はっ
親分）お？
はじめ)もしもしぃ？
親分)あ、もしもし？
親分）あれ？
親分)あれれ？あれ？？もしもーし？？？
親分)あれ？　きこえないよーんｗ
親分)ん？これつながってね？ん？
親分)なんだ？ｗこれは無音だとどうなるかみたいな動画とっ
サアセンシタアアアア！！！！！！！！！
失礼します。
宜しくお願i...
今おすすめのアニメ、
んーそうですねー...
「からかい上手の高木さん」
ふっ...
...は...！
うあうあ、ヴあ～ヴあ
ヴア　ヴあとぅあヴ　ヴあつあヴ
マァぁヴあ　パぁあヴあ
ふぁヴあぁぁぁあああぁあああ
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
あっ、
ひびき君、
誕生日...
おめでｔ
言わねええええぇいよおおおぉぉぉぉ！！！！！
おめでと
いいえ。
おうぅぅぅお
おっ、うおっ
ふあっ、あっ、あっふあっ、あっ・・・
HA)おい。
M)え？
M)もしもし？
M)え？どしたの？HA)お前っさあ！
M)うん。
HA)おまほんっとさあ
M)何？
HA)おまふざけんなよ。
HA)お前さあ。
M)あっごめん。
HA)え？
M)誕生日おめでとうって言ってなかったわ。
HA)違うんだわおま違えんだよ！！
M)え？それじゃなくて？
HA)お前さあほんとさあ
HA)早く体調治せよ！！
M)ｗｗｗｗｗｗ
HA)分かったか？
M)ありがとう。分かった。
寝ろおおおお！！！！！
やだ。
やだ！
やだ！！
やだ！！！
やだ！！！！
（たくさんの小指ぶつけてに反抗するはじめ）
いやだあぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ
どおおぉぉしてだよおおぉぉぉ！！！！！
（おのれえぇ...許さん...）
はい。というわけで
えー質問してくださった皆様、本当に有難うございました。
過去最高レベルでちょっと激しかった気がします。
25だよも、25...なんですけど...まあ
体張ってなんぼなところもあるんで、
あの、楽しかったです。
はい！で、えー、重大発表でございます。
ちょとここからはー、ちょっと真面目な話になってしまうかも、しれません。
前髪な
まあ何を言おうかちょっとちゃんとまとまってないんですけど、
まあ1年前か2年前ぐらいから、
あの、とてもありがたいことに、
ものすごく
あの、YouTube...とか
YouTube以外の色んな場所で活躍させていただいております。
本当にありがたい事で非常に楽しいんですけど
あのー、それにともなって
これもたぶん去年から言ってたのかな？
去年から言ってたと思うんですけども
時間的にも、体力的にも
一人だとちょっと...
苦しいなっていう...
いろんな面でいろんな人に今、支えてもらっております。
動画には映んないですけども、動画の裏でサブチャンネルをほぼ全部編集してもらってる友達とかもいたり、
なんか、ちょっとした物の準備とか
カメラとか、なんか細かいことを手伝ってもらっている仲間がすごいいて
本当に僕...
ぼっちだったんですよ
結構まじでね。。
仲いい友達はいるっちゃいるんですけど
そんなめちゃくちゃ毎回遊ぶ訳でもないし
基本的一人で行動してる事がずっと多くて
それでね！多分YouTubeにこう専念してこれたって事はあったかもしれません。
ただその分やっぱり全部一人でやんなきゃいけなくて
忙しくなってきた中で
もう、色々と　いろいろと、まぁ時間的な苦しさや
人数的な苦しさをすごい
うあーもう、これきついなぁって思う部分が多くてですね
そこで、あの、一人じゃなくて手伝ってもらう人もつけようと思って
色んな人に手伝ってもらったり、今、支えてくれる人がたくさんいます
まぁ結果的に言うと、ぼっちじゃなくなりました。
動画だと一人ですけど、あのー
すごい、実は色んな人に支えられて今、はじめしゃちょーのチャンネルをやっていっております。
まぁ一人じゃ無くなったから、そいつらと、遊んだりすることもあって
それがほぼ遊戯王とかカードゲームとかしょうもない遊びなんですけど、
あの～僕の中ではそれがものすごい
楽しかった。
苦しい時も仲間がいたからなんとか乗り越えられたってとこもあったし
YouTube始めたころはもう一人でひたすら突っ走ろうと思ってたんですけど、
やっぱり、仲間がいてくれて
すごく、
僕は、救われています。今。
なんだけども、やっぱりYouTubeだとほら、はじめしゃちょーのチャンネルっていう
はじめしゃちょーでやるチャンネル、みたいなイメージがあって
結局動画撮ったり編集したりっていうのは僕になっちゃうんですけど
一人での色んな限界を感じていく中、色んな人に手伝ってもらったりしていくうちに、
あの～
信頼できる仲間が、たくさん増えました。
うんで！
あの、ずーっと前から、考えてたんですけども
ようやく、スタートを切る準備が、整いました。
その最高の仲間と、
新しいチャンネル作ればいいんじゃね？
ていうことで！
もちろんはじめしゃちょーのチャンネルをやめる訳ではないです！
このチャンネルもちゃんとやりつつ、
もう一つ、別箇の、
新しいチャンネルを作ろうと思っております
うん
ようやく言ってしまった
あの、実はずっと新チャンネルの準備で色々して、おりました。
グループと言っていいか分かりませんが
とりあえず、俺の周りにいる、最高のメンバーを集めたチャンネルだと思っております。
ちなみに、まだ始まりません。
あの、とりあえず作りますっていう発表だけを
今回したかったなっていう
裏で、ずっとコソコソやってたんで
なんで、別に何か一人で動画を撮るのが辛くなったとか、
そういうわけでも全然無くて、
ただ単に、あの～
動画では写せない、僕の周りの奴らが面白いんで
そいつらで、もう一個新しいチャンネルを作って、
面白いことが出来れば良いなと、
思って、おります。
というわけで、
はじめしゃちょー、新チャンネルを作るという
お知らせで、ございました。
詳細は、またしばしお待ちください。
そこでここで更にお知らせです！！
身の回りのメンバー最強っつっても、やっぱこう皆で話し合った結果、
もう一人！！
欲しいなっていう　まあ色々あるんすよ
色々話し合った結果ちょっと、もう一人増やしても良いんじゃないかなっていう話がありまして
メンバーの、募集をいたします。
という訳で新メンバーの募集をいたします。
もう、誰でも！！あっ、誰でもっていう訳じゃねえや　ごめん
一応ですね、結構決まりがあるんですよ
とりあえず
メンズっていうのは確定で
まぁ大体こんなもんでいいです
26、7、８、９、30ぐらい
の、幅で
一緒に、YouTubeを盛り上げてくださる方を募集しております。
細かいことはね、下のURLから見れるんで
もし
僕と一緒に
楽しいことをやっていきたいなって思っている方が、いらっしゃいましたら
ご連絡の方、お待ちしております。
あの、ちなみに～
結構ガチです。
まあ新チャンネルについてまだ全然言えないことが沢山あるんですけど、
大丈夫です！このチャンネルは全く変わりません。
このチャンネルは全く変わらず引き続きやっていくんですけども、
新しいことをやりてぇ
新しいことをやりたいって思って、あの、ようやく
動き出した、新チャンネル
新しいメンバーを一人だけ、募集しております。
あの、新チャンネルはほんとね近いうちに
動き出せればいいなと思っておりますので
しばしお待ちを！！！
あの、引き続き、はじめしゃちょーチャンネル
そして
新チャンネル
あんまり期待せず
待っていてください
じゃあな！！！